[inaudible]
Google,
many Googlers here and those tuning in around the world.
Welcome.
And it's terrific to have in here.
So if you're familiar at all with politics,
economics or general government affairs over the past few years,
you're obviously familiar with Robert Reich.
Certainly there's more than a few things happening in the public spheres or
incredibly honored to be with you today.
Robert Reich,
everyone
[inaudible]
well,
thank you very much John and up.
Hello Google.
We're gathered today and a kind of,
uh,
auspicious or in auspicious moment and the history of our republic.
And I want to spend a little bit of time,
I want to spend most of my time taking your questions actually,
but I want to spend a little bit of time setting up those questions by
suggesting to you that you are part of the problem and part of the solution.
Okay.
Uh,
in terms of part of the problem,
and I don't mean you particularly,
but I mean technology is a little bit part of the problem because a,
there's been a great deal of job displacement and it's,
there will be even more job displacement.
And,
uh,
if you look carefully at the counties that voted for,
and I don't mean to be partisan and what I'm saying,
this is just pure fact.
Even though we're heading toward a fact free universe,
I'm going to stick to facts.
Uh,
just look at the counties that voted for Donald Trump.
You see that the regardless,
it really doesn't track necessarily income.
The biggest correlation is our,
is the median wage or median income in that county going down or going up if
it's going down,
regardless of where it started.
Uh,
those tend to be Trump voters.
Now you may ask yourself,
why is it the median incomes are stagnant or declining nationally?
A lot of it has to do with globalization,
but more to the point,
it has to do with technology.
Hard to separate globalization technology because technology and technological
developments and advances had been responsible for making globalization easier,
but they are quite separate in certain respects.
And although many Americans blame globalization,
it really is technological displacement.
Now,
technological displacement has been with us for years and fact forever.
Ah,
this is nothing new.
What's new is the pace of the displacement.
It is faster.
Now you are involved in all of that and we'll be involved even to a larger
extent.
Uh,
you know,
the self driving car and truck,
that's 3 million truckers and a million and a half other drivers who will no
longer be earning their incomes.
Uh,
let's say,
what five years from now,
10 years from now,
uh,
driving?
Well,
what has happened to a lot of those people is not that they no longer have jobs.
I mean,
unemployment is down,
although we do have kind of a mystery what happened.
A lot of men have exited from the labor force altogether,
but generally speaking,
the problem is not numbers of jobs.
The problem is the quality of the job,
both in terms of income and job security.
We have more and more people who are on a downward escalator in income and also
very important lay.
More people are worried about where their income will come from our next month
or six months from now.
Most people have fixed costs,
the rent or mortgages or utilities or whatever,
and they have more and more variable incomes,
which is making people nervous.
Yeah.
If you looked at 2016,
the biggest single phenomenon in the 2016 election was the rise,
both among Democrats and Republicans have what might be called populism.
But populism is sort of a catch all phrase.
What I really saw and did I,
I began to see it in the fall of 2015 when I spent a lot of time researching,
uh,
a book I was writing and I wanted to go and spent a lot of it.
I'm in red states,
so called red states,
heartland states,
uh,
in the south,
in the Midwest.
And what I kept on coming across with more and more people who told me that the
game was rigged against them and they were trying to decide.
In fact,
the first conversation I had was a group of,
of farmers in misery,
Missouri.
They were trying to decide between Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders.
Yeah.
And at first when they told me that I was a little bit surprised.
And then by Donald Trump.
And Bernie Sanders didn't ever did not strike me at the time.
It's the same sort of person.
But what they were responding to in retrospect was indignation
and the implied or explicit promise from Donald Trump and from Bernie Sanders
that they would fundamentally change the system.
Okay?
And they would make the system work once again,
for average working people or for farmers or for a lot of people who have felt
disenfranchised,
left behind and more and more worried about themselves,
their futures,
their kids.
The American dream has always been that you would do better than your parents
and your kids would do better than you.
According to polls,
that's no longer the case.
For most Americans,
they don't think that their kids will do better than they are doing.
And if you look at actual analyses,
you see that about 50% or more of children born in the early 1980s will not do
better than their parents.
By contrast to kids born in the early fifties baby boomers,
95% of whom ended up or actually have done better than their parents.
You have to understand this not only as an economic reality but as a
sociological reality.
This is a shock to America.
And when the banks and I,
I actually,
I actually think there was a,
a single point where this was set off politically and it was the bailout of Wall
Street.
Uh,
because before then,
uh,
people were sort of aware that they were getting nowhere and,
and their median wages were stagnant.
Uh,
and there was a lot of discussion about that and anxiety about that,
but they didn't think the game was rigged against them.
What happened was,
as you remember,
the big banks were bailed out under tarp homeowners,
we're supposed to be helped,
but they really got very little help and no single executive in any big bank
went to jail.
Now there may be good reasons for that.
Maybe bad reasons that's irrelevant.
What happened is out of the Wall Street bailout you had on the left the occupy
movement,
which didn't last all that long.
And you also had on the right,
the tea party movement,
which lasted for a while before it got cooptive by big money.
And so you've got to sort of uprisings in 2009 2010 2011 2012 and then you have
Trump and Sanders direct lineal descendants.
It's important I think to understand that Donald Trump did not get to be
president because of racism or misogyny or xenophobia.
I say that because racism,
misogyny,
and xenophobia had been with us since the founding of the republic.
These are not new feelings.
What Donald Trump did is utilize economic anxiety as his vehicle to channel
racism and misogyny and xenophobia and a lot of other things.
We are in an era now where the real battle is not between the Democrats,
Republicans or right and left.
The real battle is between what I call authoritarian populism and what you might
call progressive populism.
The difference between them is that an authority pilot,
authoritarian populism essentially is nativist and senior phobic tramp on not
only human rights,
but also
channels,
anger,
just scapegoats toward scapegoats and we're seeing that.
We saw it in the first week of the Trump administration and the progressive
populous movement.
To the extent that there is such a movement is pro democracy.
It's a it,
it looks to strengthening democratic institutions rather than overriding them.
Technology is good.
We cannot be and should not be.
Neo Luddites,
what you guys have done at Google and you are the leaders in the world and I
congratulate you for it.
You have great given people a vision and you continue to give vision people
visions of what can be of how life can be better and that's wonderful and don't
ever stop,
but that's not enough.
What I want to suggest to you is that there are two areas where we need your
help.
I don't know enough about technology to suggest exactly what you need to do in
each of these areas,
but I do know that we need your help.
We being our society and even the world
one has to do with
enabling people to live better,
even though they may have lower incomes now you could and we can.
If we're very clever,
we could give people the skills they need to maybe get better jobs in the
future.
That is there is a kind of skills mismatch but that's not the big,
big problem.
The bigger problem is that as we move to a new world of technological
displacement,
all of huge number of people,
much larger than right now are going to lose the jobs they have and be forced
into lower wage work.
It's not that they won't have jobs,
they will have jobs.
It's just lower wage jobs given supply and demand and less secure jobs.
So we need,
and you need to think about with people who are very much entrenched in the
world of political science and sociology and politics.
Generally you need to think about how we construct an income supplement that
works much better than the earned income tax credit and also what might be
called and his cub club a lot of things,
but a guaranteed minimum income.
In the future.
We're also going to have to get much,
much cleverer about strengthening democratic institutions.
Now in your heads,
both of those tasks that is supplementing incomes or having a minimum guaranteed
income and also strengthening democratic institutions.
They may sound that non technological.
They are,
I believe,
technological and part.
And I would love there to be some convening of those of you who are
technologically clever and creative with some people who are deeply entrenched
in the politics and sociology and understand what's happening and the economics
and try to come up with some range of solutions.
Now quickly,
let me say something about Donald Trump.
Uh,
because the issue here to me is not right versus left Democrats versus
Republicans,
a standard set of issues.
We can have differences.
We do have differences in this country,
on the environment or on women's reproductive rights or on emigration or on a
lot of issues.
And we've had fights for years over all of this.
But there's something different here.
One big difference has to do with something I just alluded to and that is
tyranny.
And I'm using that term advisedly.
I'm simply talking about I dis missile and disrespect I've democratic
institutions versus a constitutional democracy.
And on the basis of the first week of the Trump administration,
I've got to tell you,
I am frankly very worried.
The second level of my concern,
again,
has nothing to do with right versus left and it doesn't even have to do with
Tierra neighbors is democracy and democratic institutions.
It has to do with a personality disorder.
I would take a right wing president over somebody who demonstrates all of the
characteristics of a sociopath.
And I say that quite seriously.
I think we're in trouble.
Uh,
I know that there is a 25th amendment to the Constitution that provides a
vehicle for removing presidents who are mentally impaired in some way.
Maybe that's the way we go,
but I am quite shocked as some of you are at the disregard at the kind of
craziness.
I mean,
I've,
I'd been in White House.
My first job was in the Ford Administration.
I mean I,
that was a Republican administration.
Do you remember?
I worked,
my first job actually in the Ford Administration was in the Justice Department
and I worked for a man named Robert Bork.
So I am not,
you know,
although I am now labeled as a card carrying Liberal Democrat,
I have seen government for years in many different situations and many were
under many different presidents.
I've never seen anything like this.
This is,
this is a problem folks.
And it's our problem.
So another issue that I hope that you can help me with and help the country with
is how to strengthen democracy at the grass roots.
I am overwhelmed with people asking me and I'm sure that they've asked you or
they're kind of your,
your friends are asking,
what can I do?
Well,
it would be great if there were a simple app where you could get together with a
lot of people in your local congressional district or your local people who,
who feel as you do.
And you could develop a way of putting pressure on your members of Congress and
you could also get together with sister districts and purple states.
And you could also have some fairly direct and easy options for expressing
yourself and expressing yourself politically.
Because I think the demonstrations and raising a Ruckus are great,
but they're easy.
They're too easy.
What we need to do is mobilize and organize and we need to get Republicans and
Democrats together to organize and mobilize.
Cause if this is seen as a partisan issue,
it's going to be dead on arrival and it's going to normalize a situation that
should not be normalized.
So on that upbeat note,
I've given you your assignments and a,
I would like to take your questions
[inaudible]
uh,
well,
the strongest objections to universal basic income pretty predictably are people
who say,
Oh,
this is socialist,
another social idea.
Or if people get a lot of money getting money,
they're just going to piss it away.
Uh,
they're not gonna,
you know,
they're going to adjust a sit down and,
and never get up and buy drugs or whatever.
The,
the experiments that have been done to date,
and there are a number of them and there are more coming suggest that people
really don't want to just sit and do nothing.
They really,
people want to work or they want to write music or they want to read or they
want to,
you know,
people don't just sit and do nothing.
So the idea of a universal basic income as a kind of license to opt out is
ridiculous on the basis of what we know.
But we've got to get through the ideological problem in which people say,
oh,
that's socialism.
I think one way of doing it is to design the universal basic income.
So it's basically just covers minimum needs.
Depending upon where you live,
it's going to be different,
uh,
in,
in San Francisco than it is in,
uh,
in Missouri.
Uh,
but it covers your minimum needs in terms of clothing and shelter and food.
But if you want anything more than that,
you're going to have to work
that will at least quell some of the distress about this.
I think secondly,
it's got to be built on the most popular programs we have in government.
What's your social security and Medicare?
In fact,
if I were designing universal basic income,
I wouldn't even announce it as universal basic income.
I make up another word I and I'd make it title five of social security.
Hi.
Um,
uh,
my question comes from,
do you know who Chris?
Our,
Nate,
is he someone who on Twitter?
So his,
his sort of point about universal income.
His work is often the source of meaning in people's lives.
I know it is for me,
uh,
with my colleagues and so on.
So how do,
how would universal income take care of that issue?
Well,
work is a source of meaning.
Uh,
and it's also a structure that gives people meaning.
But universal basic income doesn't mean we get rid of work.
That's my point.
People are still going to work and work has by the,
by the,
by two different meanings in this context.
Some of it is paid work and some of it is unpaid work.
I charitable work is very important work.
So yes,
we want people to work,
but we don't necessarily want them to be,
have to work on three or four jobs 60 70 hours a week and not make,
even then not make enough to support their families because technology and
incidentally,
less importantly,
globalization is taking away their livelihoods.
Have you ever questioned from the door?
How can we help the people like the proud coal miners who've worked very hard at
a job that's going away,
who linked their self worth through your work and don't just want handouts and
resent the people who received them,
but they don't have any marketable skills and they just want their old job back.
Uh,
well that there's not just the universal basic income.
There is also something that needs to be expanded right now and can be,
we don't have to wait for the universal basic income.
And that's called the earned income tax credit.
That is a wage subsidy.
And if you have,
the hardest problem has to do with groups of employees or workers who are
impacted in a geographic area where there's not a lot of alternative work.
Coal mining is a good example.
I mean,
look,
those jobs are not coming back and we've got to diversify those Appalachian
economies.
And that means create new possibilities and new work and new job ladders and new
careers.
And it's gotta be relatively,
it's gotta be realistic for these people.
They'd,
they'd been promised for years.
Politicians have come in and said,
Oh yes,
we're going to have all kinds of uh,
new jobs for you,
and then no joke,
no new jobs happen.
Look,
when I talk about populist and the populist rebellion,
okay,
I want you to really understand,
and this is maybe it could be hard because you know,
you're pretty well off and you're living in the pencil in the,
in the peninsula here or maybe people that were tuning in our living fairly
well.
There are very large number of people in this country and also in other advanced
industrial countries who are on a downward escalator and that is frightening.
Hillary Clinton began her campaign
with the statement that I thought extraordinary.
She said,
the deck is stacked in favor of those at the top.
Now this is Hillary Clinton.
Hillary Clinton,
you know,
is,
is as close to an establishment figure.
In fact,
she did play the establishment figure,
ironically,
allowing Donald Trump to play the anti establishment figure when in fact,
Donald Trump is probably more establishment than anybody certainly in this room
or anybody I've ever met.
But nonetheless,
he played the outsider to her insider.
And she and he and Bernie Sanders all gave the same theme.
And that theme is the game is rigged against you.
And the reason they gave that theme and the reason any politician says anything
unless it's coming from their gut.
Then I think by the way,
Bernie Sanders,
a lot of it was coming from his gut is because political consultants and
pollsters are saying to these people,
this is what people believe and unless you really believe to the contrary,
this is where the country is right now.
Yeah,
and so what I want to stress with you is that most Americans believe the game is
rigged against them.
And it's not just because they're not doing well,
it's because they think that politics is corrupt and there.
Right.
Can I just spend a moment on this?
I mean I,
again,
I've been in and out of politics all my life and the amount of money coming into
American politics,
particularly from big companies,
it used to be you had labor unions and you had public interest groups and you
had all kinds of,
it was a much bigger mix and it was nearly not nearly as much from big
companies.
You had countervailing power,
you had smaller businesses,
you had,
you had small local banks,
you had political powers,
uh,
political parties that were located and,
and grounded in the local level.
You had labor unions,
you know,
in the 1950s one out of three people in the private sector in this country was a
member of a labor union.
Now fewer than 7% in the private sector are unionized workers.
So you no longer have what John Kenneth Galbraith.
It has great classic book of the early fifties called American capitalism.
The theory of countervailing power.
You no longer have countervailing power.
You basically only have in Washington,
big companies and a lot of money and a lot of lobbyists.
And they are calling the shots.
And what are they doing?
Well,
they are not evil.
They're not trying to be bad or evil,
but they are simply pursuing their own interests and the cumulative effect of
every big company pursuing it's own interests is what it's tax cuts for.
Big Corporations is regulatory,
so-called relief.
It is all sorts of rules for the pharmaceutical company that actually increases
pharmaceutical prices.
It's all sorts of monopolistic and monopsony mystic outcomes that actually take
money from average working people.
And where does the money go?
It goes to shareholders and executives,
but this is not a plot and I'm not criticizing anybody.
This is simply systemically what people in this country are beginning to
recognize and it's not left or right.
I had a meeting of a couple of months ago with a fellow named at David Brat.
How many of you know he is a politician?
Put up your hands if you know who he is.
None of you,
David Brat you do over there.
David Brats,
according to the congressional
conservative digest is one of the two most conservative members of Congress.
He's from the seventh district of Virginia.
Richmond.
Why do I mention him?
Because he in the primary Republican primary,
two years ago,
three years ago now,
he deposed Eric cantor
by saying that Eric Cantor was guilty of crony capitalism.
He,
his whole campaign around Eric Cantor being too close to Wall Street and too
close to big money and basically corrupt.
And I spent an afternoon with David Brat about six months ago and he could have
been Bernie Sanders except with regard to climate change and women's
reproductive rights and a bunch of others.
But on the issues of crony capitalism,
he is where a lot of republican conservatives are.
This is not a partisan issue.
And so we've got to figure out how to strengthen democratic institutions.
Oh,
it was kind of wondering what you thought might be the,
um,
or if you see a path for unions to sort of adapt and evolve in response to the
nature of the Gig economy.
And,
and also,
um,
I was thinking about wash tech and a Cwa,
just because like beyond,
uh,
their own purpose with respect to employers,
they provide spaces for barnstorms and things like that.
And,
uh,
other vital aspects of democracy.
Like do you see a public replacement for that sort of structure?
Uh,
well I,
I know that there's a movement toward associations and groups of employees that
can negotiate because they have economies of scale,
a better rates for health care,
health insurance,
pensions,
whatever.
And that's all I think to the good.
But in the retail and restaurant and hotel and hospital sectors of the economy,
you've got a lot of low wage workers who don't have a voice and they need union
representation and they're not in direct competition with globalization.
And many of them are not in direct competition right now with technology.
And so they ought to,
it seems to me have more union Howard behind them.
If you understand the drift of what I'm saying,
there's a structural change in the economy in addition to everything else that
is more monopolization.
At the same time you have le Let's unionization and if you've got more
monopolization and yes,
less unionization,
you're tipping the scales,
strong artificial intelligence will create a comparative advantage for the
country that has it.
I would also equalizes comparative advantages between countries,
the both habit.
Uh,
do you have thoughts about how this will affect global trade?
question about artificial intelligence and global trade?
Uh,
I really think we're going to spend less and less time worrying about trade
imbalances.
It's becoming less and less important because you've got more and more direct
investment,
foreign direct investments.
You've got American companies directly investing over there.
Uh,
they're coming here.
Who's us,
who's them.
It's almost impossible to tell any longer,
uh,
and to fixate on as Donald Trump has American companies and they say,
well,
we American companies have been shafted by foreign companies,
is to create a mythology that really is very misleading.
They're all global companies.
Everybody's doing everything everywhere.
And it's,
this isn't new.
When I,
I remember when I was secretary of Labor,
I,
uh,
one,
one weekend,
my wife and I,
we needed to get a new car and we went to the local and Washington Toyota dealer
and we found a perfect car to meet,
aren't family needs.
And I went,
we didn't buy it right away.
I went back to my office and my political advisor,
you know when you're in the cabinet,
you always have a political advisor.
He said,
how was your weekend,
Mr Secretary?
I said,
well,
actually,
very good.
I think we found a car.
And he said,
and what kind of car?
And I said,
well,
it was a,
it's a Toyota and he would there a pause.
Okay.
And he said that Mr Secretary,
may I be so bold as to suggest that because you were secretary of labor of the
United States,
you might pick an American name,
clay,
a car.
And I immediately,
I immediately saw the wisdom,
the subtlety of is agile
mine.
And I understood why I needed a political adviser.
So the next weekend we went to a Ford dealership and I picked out a car and I
said before we picked it out,
before we bought it,
I said to the dealer,
now you've got it.
I know this is a Ford,
but you've got to tell me what is this made in the United States by American
workers?
And he looked at me for a long time trying to decide was I one of those or was
that one of those?
And finally he looked up with a smile and said,
which would you prefer?
I'm in the back.
The matter is the Toyota had that Toyota then I looked at had just about exactly
the same domestic content as the Ford we were looking at.
I mean,
it's complete rubbish in terms of American company.
If we're talking about a big global companies,
they,
you can't tell the difference.
So as it,
I'm a little embarrassed it as a trained economist I'm about to ask to non
economic question.
Um,
so,
uh,
but in line with your homework,
which was not economic,
but the more sociological,
uh,
one of the things I personally find alarming about the current situation is I'm
a senior erosion and rejection of both attritional opinion leaders and also
sorts of fact.
So when Angela intellectual strain,
rejection of scientific outcomes,
but also something as striking as,
um,
the vast majority,
I think Trump had a grand total globally have something on your less than 10
newspaper endorsements.
And,
um,
his opponent had endorsements from papers across the spectrum and it seemed to
make absolutely no difference.
Um,
you've seen,
you know,
even today you have,
um,
a number of senior members of the Republican party coming out and speaking
against individual,
um,
uh,
positive actions by president Trump.
And it doesn't appear that that's any impact on the base.
And so it just seems this,
that can,
how do you have a,
a discussion around civics and around responsibility and democracy when there is
a seeming vacuum in opinion leaders to form public opinion.
And if banks even a rejection of by swaths of population in the intellectual
rigor that gets you to good outcomes.
Well,
first of all,
you've got to understand them.
One of the ancillary casualties of this populist revolt is the mainstream media
and a lot of so-called opinion leaders.
And that's a big casualty and it's not sudden it's been happening for years.
I remember one of the opinion leaders as you put it,
who brought down Richard Nixon was Walter Cronkite.
And those of you who are old enough might remember,
he was a news anchor that everybody watched every night.
And in the 1950s one of the people that brought down Senator Joe McCarthy and
his Communist witch hunts was Edward r Murrow who everybody watched and trust.
But now we don't have that kind of person.
And you're raising not only that problem but I ain't even bigger problem.
And that is a democracy is based on truth and it's based on shared facts and
shared analysis.
Not everybody's,
not everybody's gonna agree on every fact,
but at least there is a consensus around some key facts.
If you've got a president who spouts lies,
big lies over and over and over again and criticizes the media for correcting
him.
Is he a,
is he a symptom though or was he a cop
is both a cause and a symptom.
I mean he's a,
he's a,
he's a symptom of something that has been growing,
but he is.
And what worries me is he is escalating it big time and it's not just
dumping on the media
for criticizing him.
It's also substituting his own direct tweets.
And rallies and saying as he did last week,
and as his press secretary said,
you can't trust the media.
You can only trust trumps direct statements.
Now,
if we ever get to a point,
and I hope to God we don't,
but if we ever got to a point where the independent neutral media and fact
finders and scientists and everybody else,
they are rejected in favor of what a president,
whether it's called Trump or anything else says is the truth,
then that's the end of our democracy,
then there's no way of holding him or anybody in his position ever accountable
again.
And that's part of the attack on democratic institutions.
So,
um,
you know,
immigrants who are
skilled and able to,
you know,
it's a difficult to make that transition.
And in the past America was that place open to immigration,
a lot of opportunity and growth.
But you know,
you're saying that we were,
our expectations are going down.
So where are the shiny spots in the world and what are they doing economically
that is different here that maybe they should adopt?
Uh,
America has always been a shining example to the rest of the world of a melting
pot.
Anybody can come here and make it and it has attracted some of the most talented
and ambitious people around the world.
And that has been a huge plus.
That's not a zero sum game.
It's a positive sum game.
Uh,
and you ask where around the world,
who is doing it better right now?
And honestly,
I am hard pressed to come up with somebody who was doing it better because we
have something that most other countries don't have.
We have a polyglot culture.
There is not,
I mean there was a tradition of immigration.
Most of us are here because some ancestor migrated here.
That's,
you can't say that about most other countries.
Okay.
And so when we become nativist,
isolationist,
when we turn our backs on our own tradition,
we are not only losing our economic way because that's a huge cost for us,
but we are also losing the moral authority in the world.
That comes with being the hope of the world in terms of upward mobility.
And on top of that,
unfortunately we have a president who is,
and everybody knows this no matter what he says,
he's declaring war on Muslims around the world.
And I'll tell you something,
if he goes much further,
my recommendation to all of us here in this room and everybody else is we all
convert to Islam.
Okay.
[inaudible]
artificial intelligence is on the horizon,
but automation and robotics are taking manufacturing jobs right now contributing
to the climate that's allowed for our current president to take office.
What would you recommend to the president or to the next president to
reinvigorate the rust belt?
Well,
I'd recommend this to Donald Trump if he ever asked me as well.
Uh,
manufacturing is coming back.
Manufacturing jobs are not,
and that's an important distinction.
There's no way.
Most manufacturing jobs a,
were unionized and B were on the assembly line.
A,
you don't have those big unions anymore be,
you don't have the assembly lines anymore.
So it is a complete farce.
It is a complete lie.
Who assume that getting manufacturing back is the way to restoring the rust
belt.
I mean,
the way to restoring the rustbelt is basically to develop and more tech.
I'm going to call them technician jobs.
These are,
and you don't have to have a college degree.
One of the worst conceits that has infected this country is that the only way
you get in the middle class is having a four year college degree.
That should not be the case.
It is not the case in Germany.
It's not the case in various places around the world.
We have a lot of people in this country who should be able to get a first class
world class,
vocational technical education,
and become technicians who can upgrade and stall and monitor and develop all of
the gadgets that are going everywhere,
into,
into automobiles and into offices and every place else.
And we need these people.
There's a demand for these people.
Uh,
and if somebody has the last two years of high school and maybe the first year,
possibly the fridge,
the lat,
the next two years of some sort of a community college and get mastery of AU
domain of knowledge that enables them to thereby learn on the job thereafter.
Those are and could be terrific jobs in the future,
but we're not doing it.
We should be.
Earlier you were talking about the earned income tax credit and it's not
sufficient.
Um,
could you talk about what's wrong with it and explain it in the problems?
The earned income tax credit,
uh,
the three problems are,
it's not big enough.
That is an ought to be both larger and it also,
it's,
it needs to extend higher into the end of the,
on the income ladder.
Number two,
it's paid in a lump sum once a year,
which makes no sense at all because it's very hard for people to utilize a lump
sum.
It needs to be paid weekly or monthly as part of your regular job.
If you have a regular job or even if you have a,
a,
you know,
even if your job was part time,
you want to be able to get it regularly.
And thirdly,
most people,
many people,
but half the people who are entitled to the earned income tax credit don't even
know they're entitled.
And so there's a big industry,
uh,
that Raikes off a lot of that earned income tax credit by saying that some
usually poor person who's entitled to it.
Look at,
you're entitled to something.
I can get you,
uh,
just sign here and basically they're signing away a third to a half of the
earned income tax credit.
This is ridiculous.
It's a very important program.
It's the,
as I said,
it's the largest antipoverty program.
We have conservatives like it,
it's a,
it Milton Friedman invented it for crying out loud.
Uh,
but it needs to be administered much better.
And this is something else you all can help with in terms of making it easy.
Uh,
you know,
if there is an APP that a poor person can use to find out everything that they
are entitled to,
Food Stamps,
earned income,
tax credit,
uh,
easily is,
and they can just,
they can easily apply and they,
they can get what they need.
Uh,
and a transparent,
that would be fabulous.
Thank you for highlighting and be increasing lopsided distribution of wealth
with artificial intelligence.
Don't we see an even greater concentration of wealth to those who develop our
overlords,
especially since it will likely encroach into the higher paying knowledge slash
service industries.
There's a Hashtag you were up at all.
Avoid ruining it.
Uh,
okay.
Well this is,
I mean,
look,
we all understand.
I think that the reason that more and more income and wealth is being
concentrated is not just because the market is organized that way or it's not
inevitable.
Let's put it this way.
Some people say,
well,
it's just market forces.
Well,
there's no inevitability around market force.
It's about,
the question is always,
how is the market designed and who designs the market?
And the issue with regard to a lot of,
whether we're talking about artificial intelligence or any other kind of
technology has a lot to do with patents and copyrights and trademarks and
intellectual property in general.
Intellectual Property Law doesn't have to be exactly the way it's now designed.
Oh,
if anybody was,
who's an intellectual property expert here knows?
And I'm not certainly not accusing Google of anything,
but you know that the length of time of a patent or a trademark or a copyright
continues to lengthen.
Okay.
And with,
for example,
pharmaceuticals.
And I think in certain other industries you now have the ability of companies to
lengthen those patents or copyrights or trademarks almost infinitely on the
basis of very small cosmetic changes.
And if you have a fleet of,
of attorneys willing to go to court to support you and to accuse anybody else
and patent infringement or copyright infringement,
well you've got it made.
So all I am suggesting is that there is nothing inevitable about intellectual
property.
That means that wealth has got to be concentrated that much and the hands of the
owners of the intellectual property.
I think we would,
we would have as much if not maybe more innovation if maybe
okay.
The Holders of some of those intellectual property patents didn't have as much
of a return on those patents.
You understand what I'm getting at?
We are making choices.
Inequality.
The degree of inequality we have now is a choice.
It's the reflection of public choices that have been made over last,
particularly the last 35 years
in every domain.
Not just intellectual property,
but also antitrust.
Also areas having to do with insider information.
No other country in the advanced world has as lacks a system of insider trading
as we do.
And that creates a gigantic fortunes for those who have access in turn to that
insider information,
not because they are superior human beings or because they have any particular
expertise except they played golf with the right people.
Uh,
I have to deleted questions regarding the notion of kids doing better than their
parents did.
Reminds me of a quote from the book.
Small is beautiful economics as if people mattered and that they talk about how
can you have infinite growth when you have a limited set of resources,
right?
The world's emitted.
And so kids doing better than their parents,
generation after generation sounds like something that's akin to infinite
growth.
And the next thing is,
um,
when we talk about guaranteed minimum income,
how do we get the kids doing better than their parents?
Um,
notion.
especially if kids don't want to work and they're happy with the minimum income,
but feel entitled that they should be doing better than their parents.
Well,
let me first of all,
deal with,
uh,
the growth issue.
I mean,
everybody who works for Google must understand that technology and innovation
generate growth and there's no limit necessarily to the human brain's capacity
to innovate.
And so there's no reason we can't continue to grow.
I mean,
those people who are nervous about growth,
what they really are nervous about is excessive,
wasteful consumption and basically people filling up their homeless full of
stuff that is generating a,
just waste and more utilization of,
of,
of fossil fuels.
But innovation,
real innovation can,
and I'm talking to the converted here,
you know,
innovation can allow us all healthier,
happier,
better lives,
can save energy,
can save the environment.
I mean,
it's,
growth is not a zero sum game and it's not a,
a declining amount of possibility if everybody's on a guaranteed minimum income.
How can children do better than their parents?
Well,
to two points.
Number one,
doing better.
It does not necessarily mean simply more acquisitiveness or more,
it could be a more creative options for how you use your time.
And if technology continues to improve that,
uh,
just sort a portfolio of options,
they then people will be doing better by definition.
So it's a similar answer for both of them.
Sounds like tech similar answer to both of them.
And again,
I would have you are all in this room understand those answers better than any
audience when you talk about a universal basic income or are you imagining one
for the entire us or for the entire world?
Why do you focus on whichever of these you focus on and is there anything
positive you can say about the other one?
Well,
the universal basic income is the kind of thing that has to be financed and it
has to be financed.
And there are certain beneficiaries,
the obviously unit is a society or a nation.
Now a lot of nations can have it.
I mean we have,
or the earned income tax credit or the equivalent of the earned income tax
credit does now in eight developing nations or developed nations.
I should say and it's spreading a,
there's no reason that the universal basic income could not also be,
uh,
now the interesting question is,
and I think it's raised by that question,
could we have a universal basic income that was global?
I mean,
is there any reason why developing decisions or developing nations should not
have something like that and could it be possibly subsidized by rich nations?
I suppose that is possible.
That would be wonderful.
But I would,
I think we have to at least establish the universal basic income first,
uh,
before we start pushing it in that direction.
It's going to be hard enough.
But let me tie this back if I make us,
because we only have a couple of minutes left and I want to tie it back to
something that I said initially.
We are right now in a crisis in terms of our democracy and also to some extent
in terms of the conditions that led to our democratic small d crisis.
There is a silver lining.
The silver lining is that more people are more engaged right now politically.
Then I have seen in my memory at least since the Vietnam War,
and that is a great
thanks.
That degree of engagement does not simply mean demonstrations,
although demonstrations are great and they're important and they also can be
fun.
Uh,
and they're important partly because they convince people or they help reassure
people that they're not alone,
that there are millions of other people who feel exactly as they do,
but they can't be the end of what people do because those demonstrations have
got to be part of a very pragmatic political strategy.
Uh,
and that is,
it seems to be the next question.
Those of you who have got a hold of indivisible,
guide.com and also sister district got.com.
There are a bunch of very useful websites right now about what you can do and
how you can do it.
Uh,
and I think that we are ideally,
and again this is silver lining stuff than I am.
I am deep down an optimist.
I think we are maybe going to get to see a renewal of civic engagement and civic
activism such as again,
we haven't seen but we desperately need.
We would have needed even without Donald Trump,
but unfortunately we have Trump and maybe we would not get this kind of activism
without them though.
My question to you would be if you could speak to the challenges of gender in
both politics and technology.
Uh,
the challenge of the,
the biggest immediate
[inaudible],
the biggest immediate challenge with regard to gender right now,
right now as we stand here is the assault on women's reproductive rights.
It is major,
it is going on all over this country and it is taking shape very,
very rapidly.
A lot of you women here,
you take Roe v Wade for granted.
I was alive before Roe against Wade.
I saw what happened.
The result is not fewer abortions.
The result is more deaths and maimings and serious injuries and I think that
that to me is something that is not just a woman's issue.
It is a men's issue,
is a family issue.
We all have to get behind protecting roe against Wade and a women's right to
choose.
Uh,
secondly,
with regard to technology and women,
let me just say this,
I worked with a fellow for a number of years named Larry Summers.
Uh,
he was president of Harvard University for a time until he made the preposterous
statements that maybe women's brains are not really suited for math and
technology,
uh,
that lead appropriately to him no longer being president of Harvard.
I think that there is no reason that women should not be as plentiful in this
audience as men.
And this is not believed me in any way directly or indirectly a criticism of,
of Google.
I just mean women should be in technology.
And what we see,
and I teach at one of the best universities in this country,
my students are more than half of them are women.
And my best students are all women
not to stereotype.
So I think that women have got to be encouraged to go into math and science and
technology and it's all of our responsibilities.
Uh,
on that note,
upbeat as it is,
I want to thank you for your time and attention.
The reason,
let me just say the reason I accepted your very kind invitation to come today is
because I really feel that,
as I said at the start,
you have not only a part of the responsibility for what's happening in this
country now,
but also a big part of the solution.
And I hope I have made myself clear about some of the directions that solution
needs to move in.
A one final point on that notion,
not only in terms of technology and technological development,
I do hope that Google,
as well as other big high tech companies become very clear and articulate in
their opposition to what is happening in this country with regard to Nativism,
xenophobia,
and also an attack on democratic institutions.
[inaudible].